[Music]
okay so here's our community exercise
and you know uh what I do is not always
clearcut so try it you might you'll see
better benefits more important benefits
than just fixing EO I mean who cares
about that okay so get involved um but
here's what we're going to do and I'll
describe it in segments and then uh I
will demonstrate it okay and we're going
to film The Desi that are here too and
we'll add them to the video okay so
first what do I what do I want to see I
want to see uh from
Kat uh up to this first Ed me okay
that's what I want to see we'll do it
one more time and you can move wherever
you need to so
boom boom to okay that is where the
technique begins and ends that's all
we're working on
okay uh element number
one is I would like to see you uh uh get
this reaction here okay as opposed to
this reaction when you finally move your
arm up okay so he's hitting boom and
then you come in okay that's element one
he should be bouncing off of
you here not being push from you there
okay element number two so show it
slowly is as you coming
around I want to see a trap here okay
okay so I have my one hand on one side
and one hand on the other side so watch
How I do that part
on boom boom here here on both sides
okay element
three
h as I come
around this trap is what pushes his arm
off the grip there it is
[Music]
okay what would be contrast to element
Two element two is you over here you
have this hand across on the outside and
this hand on the inside but they should
be different they should be the opposite
the Yang hand is on the right side of me
and the yin hand's on the left side
element
three
is that this movement of my
arm is what moves this arm here not my
left hand taking it off okay such that
in element three the order
is from the
trap
elbow then grip elbow then
grip
not grip then elbow
incorrect okay and then the fourth
element is you have to refine his Center
so he cannot stay on that foot so I'll
show you we'll watch his
foot watch where that foot is I have to
be able to take his Center forward
off of that
foot towards that end we have the x
pattern with the koset coming through so
I'm not over here I go across
in
okay it'll look something like this and
you move around how you want for
different angles cuz Warren was saying
he lost the angle from
[Music]
okay try
keep your other hand in the fight at the
beginning
[Music]
right watch that Rudder of the back
foot and good
good
watch the ruding
was the
ring
more okay uh one thing I would add here
okay so when when you going here uh
notice where the height of his arm okay
so I'm not going to bring this up like
that and I'm way up here like
that okay
so it's a much
smaller Circle okay and it's not
really at his shoulder
joint okay so if you pay attention what
I mean is I'm going to make a big circle
with his
hand rotating around his shoulder
jump I'm going to take advantage that he
has these joints in there so you see
this is wrist nothing's really gone
around his shoulder joint do you see and
now I don't want to make that Circle
once once I'm there I go to the elbow
and the elbow attacks the
you guys see that
so that's that's not me
okay you see that okay all right when
when we doing like
Mak remember you you're rotating your
hands because there has to be a yin and
yang relationship there not the two
hands going together
you see that that looks weird right to
you guys but this this is how a lot of
the iido world does like ma to move
their two hands together but this is a
head do you see and then this one
follows do you guys see that okay so
that's why I said it's like the
Joe so as you're coming
around I get to the track wrap okay I
don't want to Pivot at the shoulder
because there's no there's no control on
his Center as you're doing all that do
you see it won't happen until you've
passed
everything and then now you can push on
that and that that's what you guys are
experiencing okay so when you come
around
here and this elbow
instead of making this big so watch the
degree of rotation when I make this arm
straight it's got to go tick tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick tick now I can get on it
again on the other one his elbow just
has to go to there do you see so you
don't want his arm straight where your
two arms are doing the same thing do you
see that instead this arm is doing a
lead it's leading it's leading into it
do you see and this one is following the
lead so a visual cue that you're doing
that is that his elbow is bent his arm
is
bent on the other
one his arm gets straight
okay and you don't want that your two
hands are doing the same thing as
opposed to following each other
following each other okay so again you
know I trained the recruits and they
like you go you said it was like the Joe
and on the Joe the rear hand went
first do you get
it the concept is that one hand is Yin
and one hand is Young they're not doing
the same thing in this technique the KN
hand is doing it first and the rear hand
is following okay so when I go boom
through here the Le hand is going first
okay and that is because once when you
project you you have a slight
moment of seizure of the center okay
just like in the last video you get that
little second you occupying him and so
when when you come to here you have the
center again okay so he gets up right
and can he push into me no he can't so
we do this move a lot in in the uh in
the ground fighting do you guys see it
this is the tricep move from the bicep
move okay he can't he can't push into me
so you you now have the center again you
can do what you want with it
when we get him here and you do the
other hand and you do its pattern I
don't have I don't have the center you
see he can come right into me cuz that's
where I was taking him do you see that
so you have to do the order right is
here here first elbow control okay and
then he he landed in the Trap so it goes
right hand in this case first in the
spiral followed by left hand okay now if
you pay
attention because they're passing
through Yin and yangong this was the Y
hand this is the yin hat will don't
eventually go right here you see it
turns back into the Y hat okay all right
um
so that is why the order the order of
operation is elbow wrist never wrist
elow you will almost always straighten
the
arm
and you won't be in control of the UK
Center because that's not the next
control point the control point is the
elbow and it will pass out of its
control point this and then the other
hand will pick back up okay um so
again if you go back to the symptomology
I gave you when you go wrist first you
you're going to have that straight arm
do you see just happens every time and
then your hands are together again you
see that and you don't you don't want
your hands together your hands are doing
different things they're doing their own
different PS okay